il est des collections qu'on ne choisit
pas on s'y casse les dents une fois et
puis l'on y prend goût comme hugette
Botella qui traque les fèves depuis 25
ans en repérage dans les boulangeries de
son quartier on ne lui fait pas avaler
n'importe quoi tout fait original
d'ailleurs mais ce n'est pas une
porcelaine je vois que c'est si c'est
une Porcel à tourné d'experte trouvaille
originale car c'est en chinan kugette
dégotte les plus belles pièces sans pour
autant acheter des centaines de galettes
les connaissances me font profiter de
leur trouvag et puis bien souv ent les
les boulangers acceptent après
l'épiphanie de de vendre donc les fèves
qu'il leur reste avec plus de 1000 fèves
dans ces tiroirs hugette possède
aujourd'hui des pièces rares du début du
siècle j'étais assez séduite par les
années 1900 par tout ce qu'elles
évoquent et je crois qu'au travers des
fèves j'ai reconstitué un peu de cette
époque des haricots du Moyen-Âge au
poupon du début du siècle jusqu'aux
fèves en plastique des années 60 les
côtes peuvent atteindre jusqu'à 10000
francs au vent aux encherres